welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast we are back from summer break
for season five of the podcast and in
our first episode of the season we
discuss a brand new paper that's
generating a ton of discussion about how
age and biological sex impact our
metabolic rate
after discussing these new findings we
also provide some practical strategies
for estimating total daily energy
expenditure either for yourself or for
your clients
this episode also features a research
update on blood flow restricted training
in addition to a brief discussion about
tercestrone supplementation and an
exciting announcement about our first
ever live q a episode of the podcast as
always thank you for listening and we
hope you enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host eric trexler
and today to kick off season number five
i've got a special temporary guest
co-host his name is greg knuckles greg
how are you doing
doing well how are you
i am doing well like i said we are now
in season five of the podcast uh we
recently took a little bit of time off
for summer break a little bit of
relaxation fun in the sun
we
went through a plague of biblical
proportions uh i was attacked by fire
ants to which apparently i'm quite
allergic
uh greg you had hand foot and mouth
disease uh i didn't authorize you to
share that well as a doctor and i'm
saying my doctor that is a hipaa
violation yeah and you'll be hearing
from my legal representation
uh looking forward to that i'm sure
that'll be not a problem at all very
easy to handle
um so yeah we and now we've got uh just
so listeners know
to go with the uh plague of biblical
proportions we currently have a reign of
biblical proportions so you might hear a
little bit of rain and thunder in the
background but i'm going to sell that as
a feature you know sometimes people when
they want to go to sleep they'll just
kind of play like the sounds of a nice
rainstorm so
you know put this episode on when you're
laying down to bed learn some science uh
get some nice soothing tones of a
thunderstorm in the background should be
great
um so
we're back from winter break or from
summer break uh and we are well rested
recharged ready to go it's winter in the
southern hemisphere yeah yeah
and so what that means is we're gonna
have a ton of content coming your way
over the next several weeks as we push
toward the macro factor release date so
macro factor is the nutrition app we've
been putting together we're super
excited about it we have identified a
kind of a target launch date in
mid-september
and between now and then we're going to
have a ton of content coming out so keep
an eye on the website keep an eye on our
instagram
our facebook group our subreddit that's
where you're going to find all the
different articles and other content
that comes out between now and then
along those lines we're also going to
try a slightly new format for a couple
kind of extra podcast episodes so on
september 2nd we're going to try to do a
live q a episode so we're probably going
to be using the youtube live stream
feature
and what we want to do is have a
episode that is purely dedicated to
answering listener questions and we also
want to do that live
so we're really excited about that once
we figure out the logistics uh you know
like i said keep an eye on the facebook
group and the subreddit we'll get out
all the information about exactly when
it's going to occur and how to access uh
that live event but we're stoked about
it and if you submitted questions for
today's episode either on in the
facebook group or in the subreddit we're
holding on to those until we do that
live event we'll probably start out that
event answering some questions that we
have saved up give people a chance to
kind of fill in to the uh the the chat
area uh and then you know we'll start
answering some live questions and it'll
be a great
chance to interact with everybody live
and
also a great chance for people to
actually see what i look like i've
worked really hard to not be
photographed since about 2017
all my social media profile pictures are
me in competition shape uh like four
years ago and people are often quite
surprised to see that i don't maintain
like four or five percent body fat year
round uh and and i'm not extremely tan
so people get an update about exactly
what i look like
um so with all that being said uh greg
how goes the road to the stage
oh it goes pretty well i would say uh
all things considered as you mentioned
uh i i recently uh got the plague aka
hand foot and mouth disease which i
thought was fake i i knew a foot in
mouth disease which like livestock can
get i did not realize that there was a
human analog but apparently there is and
a lot of people get it as young children
i did not so i had no immunity to it
and i have to say getting hand-footed
mouth disease as an adult
absolutely sucks uh i was sick as a dog
for about a week
and uh
still have just like skin peeling all
over my body that's a it's an excellent
visual for you uh so anyway would not
recommend hand foot and mouth disease uh
but yeah since the um
since the last episode of the podcast
aired in the last road to the stage
segment uh both went on vacation and got
very sick and was not giving a single
[ __ ] about my diet for either of those
occasions uh and i'm still down about a
pound pound and a half uh since then uh
weight trend is now below 247
occasionally waking up below 2 45
uh so that's uh that's all good stuff so
yeah i
i could have made more progress over the
last six weeks or whatever it is but uh
all things considered you know small win
is still a win and i'll take it
awesome good stuff um in my road to
enlightenment uh i mentioned in a
previous episode that for the time being
i'm not eating meat
so i wanted to make this a useful
segment
so for a variety of different reasons
people might decide that they want to
scale down their meat intake
and i have found a couple things to be
really helpful i've mentioned previously
that lentil soup is one of my go-to
meals i highly recommend it it's
very inexpensive to make very easy to
make keeps for a long time in the
refrigerator which is great for bulk
cooking
and yeah you just pop it in heat it up
it's a really nice protein source uh
that is really formed like the
foundation of my diet lately
um another thing that i've been getting
into lately is uh like asian inspired
stir fries which are fantastic
so
i found out that my grocery store keeps
like a variety of different asian sauces
that are really really good so i've been
doing these like tofu asian inspired
stir fries with these like asian sauces
i'm not much of a chef no one's ever
accused me of being much of a chef so i
don't really know
how these sauces are made or what
they're called but i can assure you that
they're very good so
if you're
limited in terms of your skill set in
the kitchen
uh and you're trying to cut down on meat
intake and you're like how am i gonna
have like a well-balanced
meal that's got plenty of protein plenty
of vegetables um
asian stir-fry with tofu is the way to
go super easy really really nice meal so
hopefully that's somewhat helpful i know
a lot of people do like uh one of the
things i see on social media sometimes
it's like meatless monday and people
wonder like uh okay if i'm gonna like go
out of my way to reduce meat intake you
know for one day of the week or just in
general how am i gonna make this work
with a high protein goal there's some
really really doable ways really easy
ways to make that work
so greg what about this week's feats of
strength
uh yeah so there there are several we've
got
three from the world of powerlifting and
four from uh weightlifting in the recent
olympics so starting with powerlifting
uh a an old favorite of the feeds of
strength segment dave rix
recently turned 62 years old and as one
does for 162nd birthday uh he squatted
282 kilograms or 622 pounds for a smooth
set of six
i think that is how most people
celebrate their 62nd birthday so i'm
glad to see he has jumped on that trend
um he does that like every year right is
he he does some kind of feat of strength
for his birthday yeah he he always
squats 600 and something for a bunch of
reps yeah uh
i i think he started that for maybe his
57th or 58th birthday and i think he's
stronger now which
really just doesn't make any sense
i look forward to his birthdays more
than my own because i'm like what is he
gonna do this time yeah and also i feel
like when i turn a new
age
i'm like uh i'm a year
closer to death but i feel like when
dave rix has a birthday he is a year
younger like well he's certainly a
you're strong he's got some benjamin
button [ __ ] going on yeah i i don't
understand how somebody continues
getting better and better and better
like into their 60s it's incredible it
makes no sense
uh all right so uh moving on
someone else who you've mentioned on
feeds of strength before andre
sapoznikov a
russian bench specialist improved his
own bench press world record by three
kilograms in the
90 kilo or 198 pound class uh he bench
pressed 280 kilos or 617 pounds raw
again at a body weight under 200 which
is
absolutely absurd
uh and then also someone else who we've
mentioned on feats of strength before
daniel zamani uh iranian bench
specialist
we've uh we've talked about this before
if you want to go back i think
three episodes i think is when we we
talked about him before uh iranian bench
specialist he's been putting up some
absolutely absurd training footage on
instagram
we're somewhat
were
[Music]
mildly skeptical about some of these
lifts because his prior competition
history
suggests that he's very strong but not
as absurdly strong as his training
footage suggests but
people also say that he used to be clean
and he just recently started using gear
and that's allowed his strength to blow
up i don't know uh
but there's
uh whatever so just to start with the
lift
he recently benched 352 and a half
kilograms or
777 pounds in the gym
uh that's only two and a half kilos off
of julius maddox's world record and so
here here's the exciting bit uh he and
julius maddox are
um scheduled to square off at iron wars
5
in january this this upcoming year uh
assuming that
that zamani's visa situation gets worked
out uh so if you if you have any
connections in the in the us visa office
pull some strings get him his [ __ ]
visa i
our our
uh editorial position about daniel's
amani's bench press on this podcast is
we very much hope that it's legit
because
i like seeing people bench press a
shitload of weight so i very much hope
it's real
um and yeah i would love to see he and
julius maddox push each other for
several years and who knows maybe after
800 falls maybe they'll bench 850 maybe
they'll bench 900.
god that seems so implausible but then
again 800 seemed very implausible just a
few years ago so who the [ __ ] knows um
anyway very strong hopefully he can he
can make it over here for iron wars 5.
yeah and it's you know it's one thing to
watch somebody chase a number that alone
is pretty cool when it's a meaningful
number uh but to watch two people go
head to head yeah adds another layer of
drama and excitement to it so for sure
hopefully that'll get sorted out and
we'll be able to see them both at iron
wars five yes sir
all right moving on to weight lifting uh
going to start with heidel and diaz a
female filipino weight lifter
she won her class and also in the
process won the first gold medal in
philippines history uh very emotional
lift very cool story uh
when the coveted pandemic was kicking
off she
actually could not get back to the
philippines after competing
internationally i believe in peru so she
was stranded in malaysia for five months
and for a period of time when she was
trying to prep for the olympics uh
her her training setup involved lifting
heavy water bottles that were just
hanging onto
uh like a bamboo stick which as i
understand it isn't ideal training
conditions
and then someone hit her up and said
like hey i have a gazebo where you can
lift weights outside for a few months uh
so she she had to overcome some
adversity just to continue training for
these olympics
much less much less winning them and
then going back a few years as well i
think two or three years ago
she was i believe erroneously uh
loosely connected to an alleged plot to
overthrow the president of the
philippines um like i said as i
understand it those rumors were not
substantiated uh but she's apparently
been dealing with like
threats of all sorts from duterte's
supporters for the last few years
because she was
connected
erroneously i believe connected to that
plot uh so she's she's overcome a lot of
adversity and uh
won her weight class by akilo snagging
the first gold medal in philippines
history uh very very cool story
um
moving over to the men's side of things
we're going to talk about lasha in a
second because of course we are you knew
that was coming if you've listened to
this podcast before
but outside of lasha i think the most
dominating male performance in the
olympics was uh shizi yong from china a
73 kilo weight class
totaled 364 kilograms that was a new
world record um
and it wasn't particularly competitive
that was a
incredibly impressive performance
from him
uh moving up a weight class to the 81
class lew salshon who
is probably one of my favorite
weightlifters so i i think my interest
in weightlifting peaked around 2012 2013
which is when lou won his first gold
medal in the 2012 olympics and that that
was when like the popularity of the
chinese weightlifting team was really
blowing up on social media and lou was
probably the biggest star of
the team at the time uh partially
because he was outrageously strong and
partially because he had and still has
just just an incredible physique he
looks fantastic
uh and he still does so you'll notice he
won his first medal in 2012
most weight lifters aren't
competitive at the top of the world for
three straight olympiads and he wasn't
young in 2012
so he
he won this gold medal at 37 years old
the next oldest male gold medalist in
weightlifting at the these olympics was
28
so
old man on the platform um still won his
weight class and people were expecting
like hey you're 37
he's been dealing with back injuries for
a couple years people were people were
thinking that he probably wouldn't even
make these olympics um
people were thinking he wasn't even the
best 81 kilo lifter in china so it was
kind of surprising that he even
qualified uh much less one and so folks
were thinking he'd probably retire like
go out on top win his gold medal right
off into the sunset but he's he's saying
in interviews that he's planning on
paris 2024 uh and stepping back on the
olympic platform at 40 years old and uh
i hope he does it he's so strong he's so
cool uh
big lou fans on this podcast
and then finally in the male super
heavyweight division lasha talakadze
from georgia our big beautiful boy did
what everyone expected him to do
set world records in the snatch clean
and jerk and total
absolutely dominated the division
greatest super heavyweight weightlifter
ever um and now he's also only one kilo
away from breaking the historical world
record uh in the clean and jerk held by
terenyenko
ever since i think like 1988 or
something like that that that records
been standing for a long time which i'll
note
uh was prior to uh
any sort of drug testing whatsoever
we are not vouching for lasha being
lifetime drug free on this podcast
certainly but the fact that uh current
lifters can't just blast gear all the
way into the competition that probably
makes a difference so
the fact that he's hitting the biggest
snatches ever the biggest total ever and
is one kilo off the biggest clean and
jerk ever uh outrageously impressive
stuff um
we're we're both big lou fans and big
lasha fans around here is it uh correct
that he had to take all of his attempts
back to back yeah yeah he did so uh
yeah if
that's worth mentioning so if you're say
a power lifter and you're not
acquainted with with weightlifting
competition uh in powerlifting you do
attempts in a round so you know the
person who puts in the lightest attempt
for the round goes first the person who
puts in the heaviest goes last everyone
takes their first attempt everyone takes
their second attempt everyone takes
their third attempt uh in weightlifting
they do a sending bar so
you know if the
weakest person in a flight says like i'm
gonna start my snatches at 150 kilos and
then my second is 153 and my third is
155 and the next weakest person in the
class says well i'm not starting until
156 then the weakest person takes all
three of their attempts before anyone
else goes the bar only goes up it never
goes down
and so
lasha is so much stronger than all of
the other super heavies in the world uh
his openers were higher than anyone
else's third attempts and so he had to
do
all of his lifts back to back to back um
so yeah i
well i mean if you watched his lifts he
was clearly good for more on this day
um
i i believe he gets paid a bonus for
every record he sets so he breaks the
records by one kilo
at a time
um but yeah i mean he
he was definitely still good for more
even follow even following himself for
every attempt but if you know if he had
more rest between his attempts i think
he'd be good for even more than that um
but yeah just just utterly dominant
performance yeah i just love the idea of
being such a standout in your class that
it's like
oh you guys are done lifted okay cool
i'm gonna go ahead and get started
like that's yeah that's just insane at
the olympic level you know it's it's not
like a local meet you know it's it's
wild um all right so moving on uh
got a research review segment this week
and there was really no question about
what would be covered in this episode of
the podcast because
uh this paper has been everywhere i've
got
so many people who have reached out
and mentioned it or asked about it or
posted about it
the paper is by ponzer and colleagues
the very same ponzer that we've talked
about on the podcast before he wrote the
popular book called burn i believe
he's most known in our area for the the
constrained energy expenditure model uh
suggesting that if
uh exercise activity gets really really
really high then there are mechanisms to
kind of constrain total energy
expenditure throughout the day
but the paper was called daily energy
expenditure through the human life
course
and this is a study where they looked at
total daily energy expenditure values
from over
over 6 400 research participants from 29
different countries
and so that sounds like a hell of a
study you know a lot of times we'll talk
about studies on the podcast and it's 20
people from the same city so you might
be wondering how does someone do a study
like this
with that type you know it's not like
they were just looking at body weight
you know you can find a database get get
the information we're talking about
total daily energy expenditure from 6
400 people across 29 different countries
obviously this was a major international
collaboration
and this is you know greg you come on
the podcast a lot and you whinge and you
whine and you complain
and you moan about the state of uh
science
and we've i don't i'm usually really
upbeat and positive but
we've talked in the past about open
science and
what open science could do and the type
of doors it could open up and the type
of projects
it could enable
and i think this paper
it's great because it got so much
attention and so many people are
interested in it because the conclusion
is
uh pretty impactful
you know so a lot of people were drawn
to it but i love that this paper got so
much attention because it's such a good
example of what some of these open
science principles can lead to
so
this particular project uh was enabled
by this big doubly labeled water
database this big kind of
uh
it's almost like a consortium
it's a dedicated project where they've
got this big database that is maintained
and it includes data from all these
different countries and all these
different research groups that use
doubly labeled water and it's got
measurements that have been taken
between uh
you know 1981 all the way up to present
and you'll see with this paper
uh
within this this one analysis they've
got data ranging from i mean basically
like newborns all the way up to people
in their 90s so the idea is
it's this dedicated project that is
committed to pooling the results not
just the results but the actual raw data
from all these different projects so it
will enable
data sharing these really
insightful nuanced analyses that simply
would not be feasible in a single lab
group so it's fantastic when people pool
these resources
they make their data open and accessible
it can enable these types of huge
collaborative projects that are so
valuable uh
you look like you're about to say
something yeah i was just gonna say as a
note
obviously it's good for science but one
of the things that frustrates me about
the fact that like open data practices
don't have broad adoption already is i
think one of the things uh standing
between
us and broader adoption of open data
practices is kind of like paranoia like
hey are people going to take my data and
like
publish findings from it before i can
after i put in all of this work
but the thing is like
so there's there's fear that it might
negatively impact your career to make
data open that that's one of the the
common
reasons for opposing open data that that
i hear discussed pretty frequently but
the thing is like this paper
is going to be cited a trillion times
like it's going to get so many citations
and everyone who contributed to the
doubly labeled water database or the
vast majority of them are authors on the
paper like this is gonna this is gonna
do like buku numbers for their h indexes
uh contributing to this database just
from this one paper is going to be
a huge thing for all of these guys
careers
guys guys and gals uh and like that's
that's the type of thing that frustrates
me about the fact that open data isn't
more common because like
there is the
very very small chance that you might be
hurt a little bit on the margins and a
very very good chance that you'll get a
chance to be on
a hugely important paper like this that
is inevitably going to get cited
thousands of times that could very much
benefit your career um so yeah
not having open data
is both bad for science and bad for
scientists but uh
you know institutional inertia i think
keeps it from being more common so
anyway you mentioned me whinging about
open science and uh
there we go yeah you're welcome
so
the thing that's uh
really cool about this is
when we write articles for our research
review monthly applications and strength
sport at the end of each article
we have a section about next steps
basically like what should be the next
study or what's a way that you could
re-design this study to kind of answer
the question that we're interested in
and a lot of times we say like well in a
perfect world the next study would be
this but who has the time who has the
money who has the resources who has the
energy
but when you look at this type of huge
collaborative effort that involves uh
you know multiple different studies and
multiple different trial sites
uh
these kind of pie in the sky ideas
actually do become feasible which is a
really powerful thing so
uh
i've probably given away the fact that i
think this was a good paper i thought it
was very cool um
a very brief note one of the reasons
that this whole project was established
is because doubly labeled water
is
a very expensive and labor-intensive
method
of assessing total daily energy
expenditure so
it's one of those things where people
realize
if we are going to you know maximally
utilize this this valuable data from
this particular method we probably ought
to make sure these data don't go to
waste we should probably pool this and
organize it accordingly so doubly
labeled water one of the biggest
questions i've seen people ask about
this paper
is
what is it you know how does it work so
when we think about measuring energy
expenditure we might think about uh you
know having somebody just kind of sit
down in a chair and doing indirect
calorimetry to get their resting
metabolic rate so measuring their
expired gases to get an idea of their
their resting energy expenditure some
studies take it a step further and they
have people stay in a metabolic chamber
usually for no more than like 24 hours
or so and a metabolic chamber is like
what if instead of breathing into a
little machine for an hour or whatever
you stay in a little tiny apartment that
actually captures all of your gases and
analyzes them and measures your energy
expenditure and so there are these weird
little
apartments where you're like sitting in
there like kind of like a goldfish and
they're measuring your energy
expenditure and you're like okay well
that sounds better than just kind of
sitting in a chair for a brief period of
time and getting only the resting
component but the problem is you have to
wonder
how much your total daily energy
expenditure is being impacted by the
fact that you're being put into this
different environment that is a little
bit restrictive you know it's still like
this weird little tiny apartment chamber
it's not perfectly representative of how
you live
your day-to-day life
and so doubly labeled water is a totally
different approach to estimating
uh your your total daily energy
expenditure and before we get into the
details of the poncer study i think a
very fair question is
what exactly is doubly labeled water and
how does this method actually work
i know a lot of people reading through
this paper or looking at summaries of
the paper their first question is you
know is doubly labeled water a valid
method for looking at total daily energy
expenditure and you know starting out
with the conclusion it's it's definitely
a valid method it's a very nice method a
lot of people consider it to be the gold
standard method
the way it works is quite
nuanced so if you want to get into all
the details of how it works i am going
to link an open access paper in the show
notes of today's episode that walks
through every last detail of how doubly
labeled water works
as a method for estimating total daily
energy expenditure but
for a very brief
oversimplified overview of how it works
this particular method works by
basically enriching the participants
body water with heavy isotopes of oxygen
and hydrogen
and then you determine the difference in
washout kinetics between those isotopes
those heavy isotopes of oxygen and
hydrogen and by looking at those washout
kinetics usually measured based on urine
sampling you can get a really good idea
of the overall rate of carbon dioxide
production and you can use that to then
estimate total daily energy expenditure
and you can do it with very acceptable
validity and reliability so it's a
really really nice method for looking at
total daily energy expenditure uh in
people who are just going about their
day-to-day lives you know they don't
have to sit down and breathe into a tube
for an hour they don't have to stay in a
special
metabolic chamber apartment for
several days at a time they can go about
their normal day-to-day life and we can
still get these really good estimates of
their total daily energy expenditure
so
they with this study they also had some
body composition data and like i said
doubly labeled water estimates of total
daily energy expenditure from a huge
group of people
uh
male and female
they even had uh some pregnant women in
the study uh in some of the data here
they had uh
age ranging from infants all the way to
uh people well into their 90s and there
were a few main observations that kind
of jumped out
so one that's probably not super
surprising
is that fat free mass is a notable
predictor
of basal energy expenditure or resting
energy expenditure
along with total daily energy
expenditure um
it's a notable predictor but not a
perfect predictor there's still a
tremendous amount of variability from
person to person in terms of their total
energy expenditure at a given value of
fat free mass so
there was clearly a relationship but it
was not a perfectly perfectly predictive
relationship by any means
a couple of the observations as you dig
a little deeper into the paper
did get a lot of interest for pretty
obvious reasons so one of the
observations in the paper is that
males and females have pretty similar
energy expenditure when body composition
is accounted for
so a lot of times you'll hear people
suggesting
that
that's not the case but but this
provides pretty good evidence uh
with a really nice large sample of
participants and a really nice
measurement method to indicate that the
main difference in you know basal and
total energy expenditure between males
and females really comes down to uh the
amount of it comes down to body
composition essentially so once that's
accounted for
fairly similar values
for males and females
one of the things that got the most
attention from this paper
kind of like the main highlight that a
lot of people were interested in
is that when accounting for body
composition
energy expenditure
remains pretty stable from the age of 20
to 60. so basically all the way
throughout adulthood until the age of 60
uh
energy expen expenditure remained quite
stable uh even during pregnancy which i
found to be really fascinating but when
they accounted for the lean mass of the
developing fetus it the model still
worked out quite well and energy
expenditure was pretty stable which i
thought was was pretty wild
um but that got a lot of attention right
because one of the most common things we
hear about energy expenditure throughout
the lifespan is like oh man i know
you're lean now but wait till you hit
insert whatever number right some people
say wait till you get 30 wait wait until
you turn 40. wait till you turn 50. it's
very it's very convenient typically that
the age at which the individual making
this claim started gaining weight
happens to always coincide with the age
at which metabolic rate slows down yeah
so i mean that that obviously it's
become such a common thing to hear
uh that this data indicating the
opposite is a huge reason that it got so
much attention
um
another observation is that beyond 60
fat free mass tended to drop
total daily energy expenditure tended to
drop but interestingly they noted in the
paper that fat mass didn't seem to
really go up and a common concern is you
know once i get to a certain age
energy expenditure is going to go down
and that's going to cause me to
have some
precipitous fat gain that occurs after
that
and these data did not seem to support
that idea rather it looked like fat mass
stayed relatively stable the main change
that was occurring after the age of 60
with regards to body composition was
just a reduction of fat free mass now as
i mentioned previously these data did
reflect a reduction in total daily
energy expenditure beyond the age of 60
and naturally these researchers
kind of dug a little deeper and talked
about some potential things that could
have been contributing to that effect
that was observed and so of course the
loss of fat free mass is going to
contribute to that when we're looking at
absolute terms uh they also acknowledge
that lower activity level probably plays
into that a little bit beyond the age of
60. uh they also
pointed towards so like even after
accounting for body composition they
still saw that like relative to a given
amount of fat free mass energy total
energy expenditure was dropping
and they pointed to potentially a
decline in organ level
metabolic rates and i was really
interested in that and so i started
digging around because like there are
these kind of accepted values that
different lean tissues have different
metabolic rates so like the liver for
example a common uh a common number
you'll see is a liver burns 200
kilocalories per kilogram per day uh or
brain tissue 240 calories per kilogram
per day heart and kidneys up around 440.
uh skeletal muscle 13. like those are
pretty standard numbers i found a really
cool paper
oh no i forget who the author is i'll
put the link in the show notes that
sounded so
insincere no that was
no i that was a very sincere i know you
meant it just the way oh no i forgot who
the author is
oh god oh no i'll put the link in the
show notes
um
no i
i thought i had it in the caption but i
don't but what was really interesting i
this i don't think this paper was cited
in the the ponzer paper but there is uh
evidence indicating that some of these
uh organ level metabolic rates do drop
uh
throughout the lifespan so the numbers
generally tend to be a little bit higher
in the age group of 21 to 30 years old
when you compare them to like 51 to 73
so for example
uh the number for kidneys and these are
all in kilo calories per kilogram per
day but the kidney number drops from
like 443 to 426
uh the brain number from 242 to 233 so
nothing huge when looking at you know a
given
individual tissue per kilogram but you
do start to see that general
idea
kind of panning out that some of these
tissue level metabolic rates do decline
with aging and these are not things that
could be attributed to just like you
know the the typical
less act you know less physical activity
a little bit of sarcopenia
going on so i thought that was really uh
really fascinating and then of course
one of the other observations that stood
out i haven't seen as many people
focusing on this in the interpretation
the main thing people are interested in
is that
flat line from 20 to 60 and i think the
data totally support that interpretation
and that took a lot of people by
surprise but one of the things that
jumped out to me is
even when you control for body
composition and sex and age
energy expenditure can still vary
quite considerably
between individuals and there's really
no easy way to predict that variation
for a specific individual so uh it's
exceedingly difficult like if we look at
you know how what should be a total
daily energy expenditure value for a
person with 52 kilograms of fat free
mass
we based on their fat free mass can that
can tell us something about the range
that we're likely to be in but it's very
difficult to
precisely predict that variation between
individuals at a given level of fat free
mass so even after you're accounting for
things like body composition sex and age
so i think that's a really important
thing to keep in mind because
we see a lot of people who
do a lot of comparing right so they'll
say like okay i'm about you know 170
pounds i'm about 14 body fat
i know someone who's also
you know that weight and that percent
body fat but i feel like they get to eat
so much more than i do we see that a lot
especially when people are dieting they
start looking around instagram and
saying like how come everybody's dieting
on such high calories even though
they're the same size as me and the
reality is there's gonna be some of that
variation from person to person and it's
because we live in a completely
inveterate flexing culture
and like
people are only gonna talk about how
many calories they're eating if it's a
flex
yeah either either like hey i'm eating
so little but still like getting by so
like i'm cool and tough or like oh man i
look great but i'm also eating so much
sucks to be you and not be able to eat
this much like
the the
normal range
for just about anything i think is like
pretty unrepresented on the internet
because like
generally it's it's only values that are
flexible
like
able to be flexed that uh
that people are gonna talk about
yeah i remember one time i was talking
to helms and uh
we were talking about
kind of maturing as bodybuilders and
getting better from show to show to show
as our careers kind of progressed
and i was like you know
the times that i started to like really
get lean and feel great about it
um
my one weird trick was that i started
eating very low calorie intakes that
like
seem almost not advisable and he's like
oh yeah that was my trick too it's like
you know you hear you see all these
people who are like super lean they're
like oh look at all these calories i'm
eating you're like oh i guess that's
normal i guess a lot of people get
insanely shredded on very moderate
calorie intakes and like
most people got to cut pretty low to get
like contest level lean
um but yeah some people
they're not lying but they are flexing
you know some people are able to get
really lean on fairly moderate calories
which is uh
feasible based on these data but
certainly not the norm uh so
skipping forward uh to some practical
applications uh that that kind of jumped
out to me as i read this
first of all
if you have low fat free mass and you
wish to lose some fat mass
your calories might have to get pretty
low you know like i i've seen one of the
things on
instagram that i've seen is
people making like broad universal
statements about like a singular
generalizable lower limit for calorie
intake that should never be crossed for
any reason and sometimes the number of
people give is surprisingly high like
though just to be very direct about what
i'm saying you'll see people who are
like no person should ever eat under
this many calories for any reason like
you're eating less than like what a
toddler needs or something like that and
like there's nothing good that comes
from eating
insufficient calories like going
excessively low with your diet being
excessively restrictive like i i don't
like to promote that concept of like oh
you should always go lower and be
tougher and grind harder that's not the
case
but
i think when you look at this data you
look at the actual values and you look
at the variability you can see why it
can be
inadvisable to set like a singular
number that represents the lower limit
for every
possible situation because you you can
look at the actual raw values here and
say like man for some of these
individuals especially the ones with low
fat free mass for them to induce
a substantial calorie deficit would
require some very low calorie intakes so
basically the idea is get away from
speaking in those universally
generalizable terms when it comes to
what low or high calorie intakes look
like it's got to be something that's
really individualized based on the
energy expenditure of that person
another thing
for adults under the age of 60
fat free mass is a major factor that's
driving total daily energy expenditure
estimates rather than necessarily
looking at sex or age and there's going
to be some covariance there right so
we might see that fat free mass
generally tends to correlate with age
within that range or with sex
within uh within that range but uh fat
free mass does seem to be one of the
things that's really driving that and i
kind of feel partially vindicated about
that
uh
it's not something that i've ever been
like super
vocal about but i've always been really
partial to the cunningham equation and i
feel like the cunningham equation
doesn't get any love
uh and i'm not totally certain why i can
speculate about some ideas but
i mean you know that i've i've argued on
behalf of the cunningham equation behind
closed doors like
i'm really partial to it i think it does
a great job estimating energy
expenditure if you have to go with kind
of a a canned population level equation
and the cunningham equation is
very simple i'm referring to the 1980
version uh
all you have there is
uh
the only actual variable going into it
is fat-free mass
and
i've always been partial to it i think a
lot of people overlook it because it's
almost like deceptively simple
um but
for a lifter who's got a decent amount
of muscle mass i'll take that equation
over some of the more common ones that
use you know height or weight or age or
sex rather than just using a direct
estimate of fat free mass so i felt
partially vindicated by that
and i should have been more vocal about
my thoughts because then i could really
be dunking on people here i
i did think it was funny when uh
when you mentioned this paper because
you know this got published uh
and it was on a day that you weren't
coming over to work and you know it was
making the round so i was like okay like
i'm sure the next time i see eric he's
gonna want to talk about this
um and and all of the headlines
related to this
were about aging
specifically um
and like we know each other well enough
that whenever a big paper gets published
and
we know we're going to discuss it
i've got a pretty good idea of of what
your takes are going to be both like
your normal takes and your hot takes but
honestly like this one caught me out of
the blue because i i thought you were
going to have something to say about
metabolic rate and aging and you came
over and you were like hey did you see
the the recent poncer paper i was like
yeah and he's like
and you were like dude
i feel so vindicated about the
cunningham equation
and uh that was not that was not the
direction i thought it was gonna go yeah
i just i don't know i think it's it's
been overlooked it's the underdog it's
deceptively simple but i've just always
felt that it works really well they said
it was finished exactly they said it had
no chance
yeah and like tinsley had a paper not
too long ago where it performed really
well
and in the chatter about that paper
there wasn't a ton of chatter about it
but i didn't see anyone going like oh
man why have we been ignoring the
cunningham equation uh i don't know i'm
a cunningham guy but anyway that's one
of the takeaways
uh another thing like a pretty obvious
takeaway i think when it comes to the
practical application is
as we age uh we start approaching that
age of 60 and beyond we certainly do
want to prioritize training and
nutrition strategies that help us
keep our activity level high while
building or maintaining fat free mass i
think that's a very uh
actionable thing that we can kind of
circle and say here's something we can
do
that is likely to
really set us up for very successful
aging delaying sarcopenia there's really
nothing to be lost
in that pursuit of maintaining fat free
mass beyond the age of 60 because they
did see that beyond the age of 60 that
fat free mass did start to drop off a
little bit
some of the factors they pointed to uh
relating to total daily energy
expenditure might not be modifiable or i
mean we frankly don't know enough and
what i'm referring to is that organ
specific tissue level specific metabolic
rate who knows how
how much we can intervene on some of
that
but the things we certainly can impact
physical activity level and doing our
best to stave off sarcopenia to the best
of our ability
i don't have any like tips for
supercharging your kidneys at this time
maybe they'll develop you know i i'm
waiting for um
we're going to talk about uh
the supplement that people are are
recommending with very little evidence
later right yes
all right so i
i would not be surprised i'm not
predicting this but i wouldn't be
surprised if in a couple years uh
you know people are like oh man you know
organ metabolic rate drops off with age
so like you know if you want to maintain
the metabolic rate of your brain and
liver like you gotta go with the
adderall dnp stack in the nursing home
yeah yeah i don't even wanna know where
that's gonna go uh
there there are just too many bad
directions to take it i'm just saying
like the
the the people who are
very invested
in bodybuilding supplements
are gonna get older eventually yeah and
eventually those those supplement
speculations are going to
drift from like
you know how can i build the most muscle
possible to like how can i live as long
as possible or like stay stay shredded
into my 70s or whatever
and i'm just saying i i fully anticipate
that like
someone is going to take this
information about
organ metabolic rates and just start
recommending like low-dose dnp to elders
yeah most likely uh
certainly not my recommendation i can
tell you that
um
another takeaway here is uh
because of the substantial variation
that we see in this data from person to
person
it's
really important to recognize that
you know
one size does not fit all when it comes
to caloric intake even if you have the
same exact fat free mass as somebody
else there's a lot of variation from
person to person which is one of the
reasons that like
you know
we built a diet app because we think
it's
good and we think it does useful things
i think when you see this kind of
variability within
a data set
you it becomes apparent that some of the
population level
uh
equations even the ones i love such as
the cunningham equation
they're only getting you within a kind
of a ballpark estimate and it's the
the day-to-day monitoring of your
energy intake
and changes in body mass
you really do have to titrate your
caloric intake
and use that information to get a really
good estimation of your total daily
energy expenditure on an individual
level you know we we can't all go
uh hang out in a metabolic chamber we
can't all volunteer for a study using
doubly labeled water so
for the
general fitness enthusiast how do we
actually figure out a really solid
estimate of our total daily energy
expenditure i think the best way to do
it
is like i said you have to monitor your
energy intake monitor how your weight
and body composition is changing over
time and triangulate that information
and that's one of the things that
if i can brag a little bit i think the
app which we're calling macro factor uh
i think it does a really nice job of
smoothing out that data and really
triangulating that information to get to
get a good estimate but um the most
important thing like i said is even if
you're not gonna you know
track it on an app or anything like that
make sure that you're being observant if
you want a really good estimate of your
total daily energy expenditure
be very observant of your energy intake
and over time consistently monitoring
how that's influencing body weight body
composition you should be able to use
that information to uh you know you can
use an equation to get you close if you
have no idea but use that information to
really refine that estimate and lock in
at a number that that's pretty accurate
for you
uh all right greg you've got uh an
update here about bfr training yeah a
little little research roundup
um
so
one of the
one of the purported benefits of blood
flow restriction training is that it can
basically serve as like free volume
essentially um
so one one of the
common things that people said about
blood flow restriction training myself
included uh is that it seems to low load
training with blood flow restriction
seems to
promote muscle hypertrophy while also
having
either
no effect or virtually no effect on
muscle damage or
um markers of of muscle fatigue or
change in performance like 24 hours post
training so you know for example if you
did
you know any sort of relatively
challenging conventional training enough
to promote a hypertrophic stimulus
you know it's probably going to take
at least a couple days to recover from
reasonably well but with blood flow
restriction what the early data was
suggesting was that it could promote
hypertrophy
with
virtually no elevated markers in muscle
damage and full recovery within 24 hours
so you could
basically add it as free volume into a
program
and not really have to to pay much of a
cost for it um however that has become a
somewhat contentious position in in the
research several studies have been
published
showing that low low training with blood
flow restriction can cause
very very substantial amounts of muscle
damage so there was a recent systematic
review published
just to discuss the blood flow
restriction and muscle damage literature
and also to try to get to the bottom of
you know not just
does blood flow restriction training
cause muscle damage or not but what
factors maybe predict whether or not
there will be robust elevations and
markers of muscle damage
after low load blood flow restricted
training
so the title of this systematic review
was effects of resistance training with
blood flow restriction on muscle damage
markers and adults a systematic review
by de quiros at all
and so there were 21 studies that met
the inclusion criteria for this
systematic review
and they were looking at
whether there were elevated markers of
muscle damage following
blood flow restricted resistance
training
so
delayed onset muscle soreness was the
most common marker of muscle damage they
looked at
but some studies also looked at
reductions in performance
muscle edema so swelling post training
changes in joint ranges of motion and
biomarkers like creatine kinase and
myoglobin
so
there were a lot of various markers of
muscle damage that they were looking at
in the systematic review and i don't
really think
it makes a ton of sense to go into a ton
of detail about all of them
uh but the the broad trend observed in
this systematic review is is basically
the determining factor is whether people
train to failure or not
so the kind of classic low load training
with blood flow restriction protocol
um is the 30 15 15 15 protocol that's
that's what was used in the vast
majority of the early studies
that suggested that blood flow
restricted training didn't really cause
muscle damage and for that protocol it's
exactly what it sounds like you use
about 30 percent of your one rep max do
a set of 30 short rest interval about a
30 second rest interval so set of 30
rest 30 seconds set of 15 rest 30
seconds set of 15 rest 30 seconds
another set of 15 and you're done so
that protocol and other non-failure
protocols used in the research do seem
to promote uh
gains and strength in untrained
individuals probably less so in trained
people uh and um
it seems also to promote hypertrophy but
also doesn't seem to result in much if
any muscle damage whereas the failure
protocols used in more recent studies
you know for example just three four
sets to failure with blood flow
restriction uh does seem to
result in pretty robust muscle damage um
so i mean that's
i i don't feel like that should be too
terribly surprising
we do know that uh
uh elevations and fatigue how long
fatigue lasts and and muscle damage
itself uh all tend to increase as you
get closer to failure uh but you know
that's basically what they found when
looking at the blood flow restricted
training research as well if you go to
training or if you go to failure you'll
probably get quite a bit of muscle
damage if you use kind of a fixed rep
protocol that generally doesn't result
in failure
you probably won't experience that much
muscle damage so then you may ask well
okay if i do
blood flow restricted training
not to failure am i leaving anything on
the table
you know does that result in a smaller
hypertrophic stimulus
i i was relatively surprised to find out
that there hasn't been much research
looking at that uh failure versus
non-failure training uh is something
that's been
researched quite a bit with with
conventional resistance training but it
hasn't really been a topic of research
with uh blood flow restricted training
uh but there was actually a paper by
bjornsson and colleagues that i reviewed
in mass either last month or two months
ago
title is frequent blood flow restricted
training not to failure and two failure
induces similar gains in myonuclei and
muscle mass
and you know the the title pretty much
gives the game away uh
the study used 17 men uh using a within
subject unilateral design so basically
each subject could serve as their own
control which uh i don't think is a
great design for strength findings but i
think that's a really strong design for
hypertrophy research uh because you're
you're mitigating um most of the random
error that could occur just due to to
sampling variability and randomization
to different groups
um
and so you know they basically had one
leg training four sets to failure one
leg doing the 30 15 15 15 protocol uh
and
observed similar hypertrophy with both
protocols so it
it seems that at least over the short
term it wasn't like a super long term
training study but it seems like at
least over the short term uh you both
don't experience as much muscle damage
if you don't go to failure
and you don't really seem to be leaving
much of any hypertrophy on the table by
avoiding failure so
um
you know generally i wouldn't like
generally i don't recommend training
protocols ripped straight out of a
resistance training study um you know
because they're
generally like fairly cookie cutter like
one size fits all and not overly
creative training prescriptions but as
far as the blood flow restriction
research goes there have been a lot of
studies that use that exact 30 15 15 15
protocol 30 seconds between sets it has
a really strong track record seems to do
everything you want blood flow
restricted training to do promotes
hypertrophy doesn't seem to cause much
if any muscle damage
so i mean i i think that's worth giving
a shot if you want to do some some bfr
training
30 of one rm is kind of the
stock intensity that people work at in
these studies but i i think a decent
rule of thumb is that
uh the first three sets definitely
shouldn't result in failure i think if
you can get at least 12 13 reps but
maybe fail on the last set or maybe just
have two or three reps on the last set
uh i think that's a pretty good
indicator that the load you're using is
is pretty appropriate
um so yeah overall uh non-failure bfr
training seems seems to be pretty good
[ __ ] uh but if you do do bfr training
for multiple sets to failure it will
probably result in
pretty robust elevations and muscle
damage
um
and then there was one other bfr paper i
wanted to talk about
this was also a systematic review and
meta-analysis by pereira nedo and
colleagues title is effects of exercise
training with the blood flow restriction
on vascular function in in adults a
systematic review and meta-analysis
and
i feel like this
this systematic review
may not be
interesting to anyone listening to this
podcast but i personally found it pretty
important
um because one of the
potential risks that that folks have
been whispering about for a while
related to bfr training
is not that bfr training will have a
negative effect on vasculature but that
uh one of the benefits that you get with
resistance training is it tends to
improve vascular health you can
increase vascular compliance of your
arteries and arterials
you can get increased capillarization
those are
those are beneficial effects of really
any type of exercise training but also
you know for our purposes here at
stronger by science those are benefits
that you can get with resistance
training
um
and folks have been
suggesting that possibly you may not
accrue positive vascular adaptations if
you primarily do blood flow restricted
training and one of the reasons for that
is uh one of the main triggers of
vascular adaptation with exercise
training is uh shear stress along the
vessel walls basically you know blood
starts blood starts pumping uh it's
moving fast through the arteries and
arterials that's causing shear stress
along the endothelium and that kicks off
signaling cascades that both lead to
acute changes so you know in the case of
exercise dilation of the vessels to get
more blood to active tissues but also
kicks off signaling cascades that result
in the longitudinal adaptations to
vasculature that we want with exercise
and it's been suggested that maybe that
doesn't occur to the same extent with
blood flow restricted training
you're cutting off venous blood flow but
you know maybe the the cuff pressure
messes with kind of the kinetics of
arterial blood flow as well maybe
resulting in a little bit less shear
stress on the artery walls uh maybe
therefore failing to cause beneficial uh
vascular adaptations to blood flow
restricted training that's that that's a
possible mechanistic
uh outcome that that people have been
speculating about
so what this systemic review and
meta-analysis wanted to do is
basically say like well is
is that true does blood flow restricted
training um lead to smaller positive
vascular adaptations than conventional
training does and long story short
no it doesn't really seem to make much
of a difference
they looked at markers of both
vascular
structure and function
and basically found that blood flow
restricted training had similar effects
on vascular structure compared to
conventional training uh and that it may
have larger positive effects on vascular
function primarily they they were
looking at studies
that measured flow-mediated dilation and
reactive hyperemia as their their
measures of vascular function um so
suggesting that maybe blood flow
restricted training actually has larger
beneficial effects on vascular function
than
conventional training does so it's worth
noting that um
the the systematic review portion had
quite a few studies in it i think like
29 studies made the cut
uh but due to heterogeneity and outcome
measures there there were only i think
like five or six studies in the actual
meta analyses
uh that that they could perform so that
this is still like pretty tentative uh
so i'm
certainly not claiming that this is
strong evidence that oh actually if you
care about vascular health blood flow
restricted training is better than
conventional training i i think that
that's still
a very very tentative potential
conclusion but i i do think
uh that that this systematic review and
meta-analysis at minimum suggests that
blood flow restricted training is
probably not worse for positive vascular
adaptations than conventional training
is
uh so
you know if if you had been exposed to
the
uh anti-bfr for vascular health
perspective uh this systematic review
should hopefully put your mind at ease
and if you had never been exposed to
that perspective before um
you know probably not something you need
to worry about
all right good stuff
um now i've got a little segment here
that we call coach's corner which is
usually when we do something really
applied and what i wanted to do this
week is kind of build off that study by
poncer and colleagues that's got a lot
of people interested in total daily
energy expenditure a lot of people
wondering what theirs is a lot of people
talking about this so what i wanted to
do with this coach's quarter
segment is basically you know
if you have no idea what your total
total daily energy energy expenditure is
and you're thinking about starting to
change your diet a little bit maybe to
induce a caloric deficit or a caloric
surplus or just make sure that you're
staying at maintenance getting a decent
estimate of total daily energy
expenditure can be a really helpful
thing so if you're just getting into
dieting this can be great uh
another potential application is if you
are a coach who works with a lot of
people uh
with their nutrition then this is the
type of thing that you'll want to figure
out when you're working with a brand new
client and you have no information about
what their diet is like you know you
have to start somewhere with an estimate
of total daily energy expenditure so i
wanted to walk through some very quick
basic ways that you can get in the
ballpark when it comes to that
estimation so uh first of all
a little bit of uh
review information here but total daily
energy expenditure has multiple
components we've got our resting energy
expenditure or our basal metabolic rate
it's usually like 60 to 70 percent of
total energy expenditure we've also got
thermic effective feeding usually around
10 percent exercise activity
thermogenesis usually estimated at about
five percent but obviously that's
subject to
a lot of variability because if you
choose to exercise a ton that's going to
go up
and then we've got non-exercise activity
thermogenesis which is
usually around 15 or so and this is just
the energy you're spending doing active
stuff that isn't intentional structured
exercise so walking around the house
raking leaves in the yard vacuuming you
know the drill all that kind of stuff
so
now that we know what makes up total
daily energy expenditure we got to find
a way to estimate this
without a lot of knowledge going into it
you know we're kind of starting with no
information aside from just baseline
characteristics of the individual
so one way we could do it is the method
that i call assuming you could assume
you could estimate or you could observe
so when i say assume basically what
we're going to do is a very basic
calculation based on your body mass to
say okay your total daily energy
expenditure might be around this range
so
for a lot of people
assuming a total daily energy
expenditure of about 14 to 16 kilo
calories per pound of body weight
actually tends to work okay
this is obviously a really really rough
estimate but for a lot of people it gets
you within the ballpark so uh for the
people who don't use freedom units that
is 30.8 to 35.2
kilocalories per kilogram of body mass
so if we're working in pounds very easy
take your weight multiply it by 14
multiply it by 16. this gives you kind
of like an upper and lower boundary of
the range that you might be looking at
and you can kind of use your intuition
from there and say okay i think i'm
going to start out with my estimate
being
either on the lower end or the higher
end whatever the case may be so it's a
very crude estimate but it's a very
quick estimate
now i mentioned you you could do this
assume approach
or you could do the estimate approach
and the estimate approach
involves using kind of standard uh
population level equations these are
equations that we alluded to a little
bit earlier so
what you do is you start out by
estimating
resting energy expenditure and then you
use a multiplier a correction factor to
account for physical activity level so
for the meta for the resting component
there are quite a few validated
equations there's uh the revised harris
benedict equation there's the mifflin
saint-georg equation there's the
cunningham equation i mentioned earlier
there's also the catch mcardle equation
those are kind of the four that have
captured my interest the most uh in in
past years uh like i alluded to earlier
i think the revised harris benedict
equation does pretty well for
non-lifters for lifters i certainly
prefer the cunningham equation because
there can be uh you know their baseline
characteristics might not very
accurately reflect their fat free mass
and i think the revised harris bennett
equation a lot of those terms are really
just kind of
uh they're just they kind of co-vary
with fat free mass so you're kind of
getting at somebody's fat free mass by
looking
at their sex their weight their height
their age so i think the cunningham
equation could be used across the board
but
certainly for lifters who tend to have a
little bit more fat free mass than the
general population uh i usually go with
the cunningham equation for them so you
use one of those validated equations to
get your resting expenditure and then
you multiply by a correction factor
now the standard correction factors that
just about everybody uses
it it goes from sedentary to extremely
active there are five categories right
so
the sedentary category is inactive job
plus very rare or minimal exercise
and the extremely active is hard daily
exercise and other regular physically
demanding tasks but what it what if i
have a sedentary job but i also do hard
daily physical exercise
well that seems to describe a absolute
[ __ ] ton of people doesn't it
interesting yeah so how do the
traditional correction factors account
for that
they just make you frustrated and
confused is is there a better is there a
better way there is a better way oh
interesting yeah so that's honestly when
we were developing macro factor one of
the things that drove us nuts is that
like it's not like you have to find some
edge case to make this
uh a nebulous concept it's like most
people look at these five categories in
the description for each and they're
like dude none of these apply to me
because like
my activity outside of the gym is fully
uncoupled from my activity inside the
gym so like there are a lot of people
who are generally active and do not do
structured exercise but like i don't
know maybe 60 percent of our audience
probably works a sedentary job doesn't
do a ton of physical activity but trains
really hard in the gym several times per
week and so none of these typical kind
of classic categories really apply to
those very common scenarios like like i
said it's not like it's truly a baffling
oversight it is because like in
developing the app we've tried to think
of so many edge cases that would cause
this to not work well or that to be uh
kind of contradictory right but like
with this it was like well these just
don't work they just don't do what
they're intended to do very well yes
someone fitting neatly into one of these
categories is an edge case yeah so so
anyway we were so annoyed by that that
we're like screw it we're making our own
for the purpose of the app so
uh what we do is we separate out your
general physical activity and your
structured exercise activity so
we basically add the two of them
together to get the correction factor so
starting out with general activity level
that's kind of the base of your your
correction factor so we say if if you're
pretty inactive pretty sedentary that's
a 1.2 if you're moderately active that's
a 1.4 but if you're if you're really
active outside of the gym you know
really high level of non-exercise
physical activity that would be a
1.6 and then on top of that we're going
to add an additional correction for how
much you train so
zero training sessions per week you add
zero
one to three sessions per week you add
0.1
6 training sessions per week you add 0.2
and if you train seven or more sessions
per week you would add 0.3
and so that keeps us within the general
range that the classical correction
factors would cover
but it doesn't drive you insane when
you're trying to figure out what
category you fit in because you train
really hard five times a week but you
like literally don't move all day which
is uh pretty much me right now uh all
right so
we you know i think it's pretty clear
that
the very basic you know just multiplying
calories by body weight is a very crude
way
to uh to kind of assume a given value
for total daily energy expenditure i
think the estimation approach using the
combination of validated equations plus
the correction factor is certainly a a
step in the right direction and is an
upgrade uh but of course
the other possibility you could assume
you could estimate you could also
observe and observing is where you take
things a step further this is a much
higher investment in terms of
time and energy and effort and attention
but
it will get you even closer to a much
better estimate of your total daily
energy expenditure because those uh
validated equations do a pretty good job
for a pretty good portion of people out
there
but they cannot really account for that
variation from person to person that was
really highlighted in that ponzor paper
so obviously with the observe approach
you're going to have to accurately
monitor your daily weight measurements
so the more accurate you can get them
the better so a good strategy is getting
those weights in the morning wearing a
standardized amount of clothing wake up
use the restroom no food or drink get
your morning weight and then move on for
for the day
that's the kind of most standardized way
to do it if possible
you also want to accurately monitor your
daily caloric intake
that's going to be an important part of
the process here now monitoring daily
calorie intake isn't for everybody there
are a lot of people who when they start
to monitor daily calorie intake they get
a little bit too
fixated on that it can cause some
psychological distress it can feed into
some disordered eating behaviors and if
that's you then daily tracking of
calories probably isn't the right
strategy for you and that's totally okay
there are other ways
to take control of your diet
and kind of manipulate it in a way that
is conducive to whatever goal you happen
to have at that time but
if monitoring monitoring daily calorie
intake is something that works for you
it's a really nice way
to get a really solid estimate of your
total daily energy expenditure the only
shortcoming here
this approach of observing can be
obviously thrown off if you have
inaccurate or inconsistent data when it
comes to your daily weight or your daily
caloric intake another potential
shortcoming is some people really get
thrown off by erroneously interpreting
their day-to-day fluctuations in water
weight so if you see the scale jump
around two pounds
you know you have to really carefully
consider how much of that is likely to
be actual tissue whether it's fat mass
or fat-free mass and how much of it is
probably just a shift in water weight
so there are some challenges with this
particular approach if you're just kind
of doing it with pencil and paper
when it comes to putting together macro
factor what we try to do is observe uh
or we tried to combine the two different
approaches of estimate and observe so we
do use estimation equations based on
baseline data to try to get a good
starting point
based on your baseline characteristics
but then through daily monitoring of
body weight and your dietary intakes we
triangulate all that information uh we
we make estimates based on the
metabolizable energy of different
tissues that could be gained or lost in
the process when you triangulate all
that data and combine it you can get
yourself to a very accurate estimate of
total daily energy expenditure
in a pretty short amount of time and
one of the ways we tried to get around
over interpreting some of that
day-to-day water weight fluctuation was
by uh
implementing some smoothing features
that we think handle that kind of
variability really well
so it a lot of people as we're talking
more about the app are wondering you
know
generally how it works that's kind of
the way that we approached it and
through our piloting and through our you
know alpha and beta testing seems to be
working pretty well but even if you
don't want to buy the app which is
totally fine you know this is kind of
the entire road map of if you're
somebody who wants to estimate your
total daily energy expenditure
this kind of takes you from the simplest
way to do it to the most complex and the
most labor intensive
and so where you fall on that spectrum
totally is up to your preference and how
you wish to approach it but i think the
value of knowing that number should be
pretty self-explanatory
uh when we're trying to make changes in
body composition it's all about
implementing a large portion of it is
about implementing a caloric deficit a
caloric surplus or staying at
maintenance if that's your goal the best
way to facilitate a good diet plan for a
given body composition goal
is by knowing total daily energy
expenditure so then you can kind of plan
your caloric intake from there
so uh
yeah we we looked through the ponzor
paper uh with some of that really cool
new data that was you know like i said i
was really stoked about that project and
the paper that came from it
and now that gives a more practical look
uh to help people out when it comes to
figuring out either your total daily
energy expenditure or if you're working
with new clients how to work toward
getting an estimate pretty quickly for
them
now moving on uh like i said we're going
to save a lot of the q a questions for
the live q a extravaganza the event
everybody's talking about on what was
that september 2nd i think
yeah seems about right uh but we did
want to answer one question this week
because
i swear this question is because it's a
question we get every week it seems like
every week i mean honestly 75 of the
time that you say hey anybody have any
questions we get a question about this
and so we figured we should probably
address it and to me it seems like a
confusing question
because it feels very out of left field
like we we get a lot of questions like
ah hey my squat technique is janky what
can i do to fix it or like
hey you know i i'm turning 50 next year
like what are some tips for aging
lifters it's like okay like those are
those are common questions that a lot of
people are going to have that's like
squarely within the realm of things that
people seem to think about a lot but
this one uh we we get all the time and
i have always found it very confusing
yeah and so the question is basically a
single word uh
tercesterone
like it's it
there's just this
pervasive question that comes up every
couple weeks it's just like what do you
think of terrestri uh tercesterone does
tricasterone work
and it comes down to left field because
it is not one of the classics
it is not like a staple in the
supplement world you know there are some
staples in the supplement world that
have low efficacy but you see them
coming right i mean
there's the the kind of classic group of
supplements that don't really do much
but you hear about them all the time but
tercesterone is a new supplement on the
block or at least it's new to us
uh
so first i want to take a step back so
tercastrone is a phytoecti steroid and
phytoectisteroids are a very cool aspect
of plant and insect biology so i was
reading through a paper that was talking
about like
out in nature what what are these
compounds up to
and so uh
a really interesting facet of
phytoactive steroids is that plants can
synthesize these compounds
basically as a defense mechanism against
the insects that would eat them and so
uh the insects would
eat a plant that has made a particular
phyto-ectisteroid
and
these compounds when they the insects
ingest them they induce molting and
ultimately it kills the insect
which is like
a very heavy metal way to defend
yourself as a plant like the insect
basically uh
eats this and
i apologize for any biologists because
i'm going to oversimplify molting but
it's basically like the the insect eats
it and then just kind of disintegrates
you know like like molting is like a
shedding of the exoskeleton uh and yeah
so it's it's like a really horrific way
for uh for an insect to go i imagine but
anyway
that that's what what that's where we
get them in nature the plants make them
the insects eat them molting is induced
and it's a bad deal but people have
extracted these from plants and
you you know been interested in their
potential use as dietary supplements
really going back several decades uh
there was a lot of res a lot of
literature coming out of the soviet
union uh several decades ago looking
into a variety of different phytoactive
steroids and uh
i my prediction my bold prediction
back in the day everybody was talking
about beta ectd ectisterone and that
kind of died down a little bit and right
now a lot of people are talking about
terkesterone uh apparently there's over
400 phyto-ecti steroids that have been
identified
so like if we keep doing the like
musical chairs with these we will never
run out so i'm kind of in this for the
long haul here um but anyway the natural
question would be
what are these supposed to do and for
for a while a lot of people are like
well
ecti steroid uh
sounds like steroid maybe they're
anabolic you know uh people have looked
at whether or not they have any anabolic
or androgenic properties when it comes
to tercesterone the most common
mechanism thrown about
is that they are agonists of the
estrogen beta receptor
and that that would be the mechanism by
which they promote
anabolism or hypertrophy of muscle
now
where this gets interesting is kind of
looking through the volumes of human
data to see if they support that
so
speaking on ecti steroids in general
phytoactive steroids in general uh the
issn had a position statement in 2018
that was just like looking at all
supplements
and they were they presented a very
skeptical take of phytoect steroids as
performance enhancing supplements uh a
2018 supplement paper by the ioc kind of
like a big group paper by a bunch of
sport nutrition experts didn't even
mention phytoactive steroids in the
paper they kind of covered the things
that seem like they work the things that
probably you ought to skip out on they
didn't even mention uh phyto-ecti
steroids there
so i was like okay well i can't lean on
you know these previous reviews uh
because they're barely even talking
about phytoactive steroids let alone
tercasterone a specific one
and like
dude i can't find any like
relevant human literature looking at
tercastrone no i do same here so i was
working on the podcast outline last
night uh and i think we both had the
same thought we got another question
about tercesterone and so i think we
were both like okay well we've got to
talk about this sooner or later so i was
on pubmed at like 2 a.m and i was just
scrolling through results looking for
human trials
i was like there's so many people
talking about that so i i expected this
to go the way that a lot of supplement
hype
goes so like for example a few years ago
uh d-aspartic acid got really
popular and like really hyped there for
a second because there was some some
mechanistic stuff suggesting that it
maybe regulated the uh the activity of
the protein or of the enzyme that's like
the rate limiting enzyme in testosterone
synthesis and the latex cells uh
and then a human trial gets published
showing that like oh man this boosts
testosterone by 40 this is good [ __ ] you
know study didn't look at strength or
hypertrophy outcomes but people see a 40
boost in testosterone in humans and say
like okay like we're going all in on the
aspartic acid now but it takes that
it takes that first human trial and you
know i should note that other d-aspartic
acid studies have have failed to
replicate that finding and it uh it
doesn't really seem to do much for
hypertrophy uh or testosterone but
anyway like generally that's the way it
goes like there's some cell culture
stuff maybe there's some rodent stuff
and then uh you have the first human
trial with some promising results and
then then the hype train leaves the
station
with with terkesterone
maybe there's a human trial somewhere
i couldn't [ __ ] find it and then
after looking on pubmed i just googled
terkesterone uh to find like you know
people who sell it shilling it
to be like okay well i'm just gonna look
at their bibliographies because like
maybe they're citing a human trial in
like some obscure journal that's not
indexed by pubmed
and i couldn't find any human trials in
like
any of the sales materials for it either
so i
i i can't claim with 100 certainty that
none exist but if they do i couldn't
find them and no one's talking about
them so that
and if they do exist by the way please
do send them over because like oh yeah
i'd love to see them if they're out
there yeah so if you have your hands on
some good human trials
uh
ideally with relevant outcomes uh please
do send them our way we would be very
enthusiastic to see him
but uh but yeah so
i didn't mean to cut you off there but
uh that's about all i had to say yeah so
we're both in the same boat we try to
find some evidence for this because like
that that's
to me that is like
when people come to me with a supplement
question my first thought isn't like huh
let me get out the whiteboard put
together some mechanisms and kind of
determine if it should work like my
first thought is like well let's see
what's going on in the actual trials
that that are most relevant and uh when
it comes to tercestrone
you know hey
maybe it does do all sorts of cool
things but but we just don't have the
human trials necessary to say with any
degree of confidence like oh safe bet
this is a really effective ergogenic aid
and you know for me i think
when i when i write about supplements
when i talk to consumers of supplements
and when i talk to producers of
supplements because i do advise some
some people that make supplements uh
i i basically
say like listen there is a certain
burden
that goes with
you telling me
that you have a supplement i should buy
from you you know there is a burden to
show me
first of all that the ingredient is
reliably dosed and i have seen with a
lot of other phyto-ect steroids that
they are notoriously bad with regards to
how
often or i guess i should say
infrequently
the label claim matches the amount of
ingredient that's actually in the
product so
that is a thing we know
i think they're in season one or two of
the podcast we talked about a study
about
beta-ectesterone if memory serves yeah
and
if you just looked at the results of the
study it seemed like oh yeah like this
this works pretty well but then they
also did like chemical analysis of the
actual supplement they were giving
people and i i don't remember the
numbers right off the top of my head but
i want to say they found out it was
underdosed by like 90 percent they
thought they were giving people like 40
milligrams a day and they were giving
them like four right and they were just
like well
i mean either either this shit's like
super powerful
and
causes uh you know ergogenic responses
with incredibly low dosages or
you know we just got some false
positives and small sample research yeah
so i i have seen some papers explicitly
like the entire purpose of the paper was
to say like hey just so you know
these different phytoactive steroids uh
the the labels just aren't matching the
independent
analysis for a lot of the stuff we're
buying off the shelves
so
like i said the burden on somebody
selling a supplement or trying to make a
compelling argument in favor for it you
got to show me that it's reliably dosed
you got to show me that it's safe that
it's bioavailable and that it gets to
the target tissue in vivo and human
beings you got to show me that it
induces clinically relevant or
practically relevant effects
and you got to show me that all this
stuff is occurring in a fairly
generalizable population and i'm okay
with making some stretches you know so
like a good example of that is
a lot of
the research unlike sleep supplements is
conducted in people diagnosed with
insomnia or something so you're like
well i don't have insomnia but i'm
looking for a little sleep aid i'm
generally comfortable with say okay well
we can use some of this insomnia
literature and see if we can kind of
generalize it out to someone who's just
having maybe not diagnosed insomnia but
some trouble sleeping at night you know
like
there there is some degree of general
generalizability that you often have to
be comfortable with because like you
know we always say for example oh
when we're talking about bodybuilding
stuff it'd be great to do this studying
bodybuilders well it's not going to
happen there's just not not that many
studies that sample bodybuilders so as a
bodybuilder with most your supplement
literature you have to say oh well these
folks have been lifted for a couple
years that works for me you know so
i'm totally comfortable with you know
embracing some amount of generalizing
from
one
population to a closely related
population but it's got to be from my
perspective more than
in vitro stuff
in a petri dish it's got to be more than
a mouse model i'm not ready to see a
really problem because for a lot of
these phytoactive steroids i believe
including terkestrom they have
the in vitro stuff that looks good
they've got a little bit of the rodent
stuff that looks good but we're still
several steps away from
where i would say
yeah this is you know clearly evidence
of a really solid ergogenic
aid that you can rely on so the
important thing to keep in mind here
is that
the absence of this evidence
does not indicate that this is an unsafe
or an ineffective ingredient there's
just simply no human evidence that we
can look at to say oh yeah i totally can
predict what this does you know so
uh it's it's certainly popular and
that's probably the only
the only actual inference i can make
after scanning the internet is that it
seems popular
yeah i mean i i would also say if like
your standard of hey is this supplement
worth trying
if your standard is like
there's two cool cell culture studies
and someone's talked about it on a
youtube channel
boy i hope you have a thick wallet
because uh
there are gonna be a lot of things that
fall under that umbrella and probably 95
of them aren't going to pan out
yeah dude so
in the process of searching for this on
the internet i did find some like
reddit threads of people who are like
hey guys i'm going to take turkesterone
and kind of document the experience
follow along if you want
and the first one i think i only looked
at one
but yeah the the poster did a really
nice job kind of setting the scene
here's where i'm at here's my training
experience here's what i'm trying to
accomplish here's what my training is
going to be like here's my diet also
just for context here's the other
supplements i'm taking dude i've never
heard of like 40 of them and like most
of what i do is write about supplements
these days like or a decent portion and
uh i'd never heard of some of this stuff
the list was like a mile long and i i'm
like yeah that kind of makes sense like
you could tell that that's a person
who's eager
when they get a little bit of evidence
say oh i'm definitely throwing that in
the mix because like yeah if you
regularly take like 14 supplements a day
i think that generally indicates that
you have a fairly optimistic view when a
new supplement comes down the line uh
but yeah so you know i i have no
evidence with which to stifle anyone's
excitement enthusiasm or optimism about
tercesterone but i also
have no evidence whatsoever to say that
that it's going to be an effective
ingredient
all right speaking of supplements uh
i'll tell you what you ought to do head
on head down to bulksupplements.com
uh we've got the code sbs pod that's in
all caps if you use that code at
checkout
over at bulksupplements.com
you get five percent off your entire
order so if you want to you know get
that list of 14 15 16 supplements to
take daily that's where you'd go about
doing it
uh finally to play us out uh greg it's
you know it's been a long summer break
we've been missing all the food content
what do you got yeah so uh we're going
we're going back to food content to play
us out uh and i'm talking about a recipe
that i haven't made in over a year but
i'm going to make tomorrow uh and that
is scotch a ragusana um so scotch a is
it's an italian thing uh and i don't
think it's
like
i've never seen it on a menu anywhere in
the us
but uh yeah we we get together with
friends every weekend make some good
food
and
you know we were kind of like thrashing
around to think like hey what's
something good that we haven't made in a
while
um and i remembered scotch a from a
video that uh chef john at food wishes
made about a year ago
um and i remember like holy [ __ ] that
stuff is amazing so i've seen it
described as lasagna bread uh so real
stronger by science heads know that
we're we're a very passionate podcast
when it comes to lasagna
um all forms of lasagna by the way
all of the real forms of lasagna but
yeah basically you make a thin
a thin dough out of semolina um
and then you top it with you know sauce
cheese various things and then you fold
it over and then you top it again and
then you fold it over again and then you
top it again and then you fold it over
again
and
basically it comes out like just imagine
that there was a lasagna hot pocket
where
each
where there were like clear distinct
layers of dough like the the semolina
dough ends up ends up with a texture
very very reminiscent of like a nice al
dente pasta
um
but yeah it's it's like a self-contained
vessel and it's so good and i'm i'm
gonna make some this weekend and i'm
very excited about it um so if you want
a
a nice little food project just to mess
around with it's not that hard to make
uh if you're
someone who's just getting into making
dough if if like making bread is
something that appeals to you but like
you're a little bit intimidated by
making dough this is a very very simple
dough to make
it's really easy to work with it's not
super wet it's not super sticky so you
can you can get some practice build up
your confidence um
but man it's so good i'm gonna make a
red sauce and cheese one i'm gonna make
uh ricotta and fried eggplant one uh
making my own ricotta tonight looking
forward to that
um
and then apparently a very
popular like traditional scotch a
topping i guess filling um
is like broccoli cauliflower and cheese
i have not made that iteration before
but i'm gonna give that a shot as well
um
but man scotch a is so good um i'll i'll
link the the chef john video
um in the show notes but you should
check it out it's a truly exceptional
food and i am
excited to dive back into that world
and i don't want to do this to you but
uh we had the lasagna showdown that i
think
i think a lot of people
are saying it went pretty favorably for
me
i am thinking about upstaging you this
weekend
when you
[Laughter]
when you make these i
actually this is kind of a throwback
this is one of the first foods i started
cooking when i got into cooking um i'm
going to bring a hot pocket
and i'm not going to tell you what
flavor
but
the way i i don't heat it up the way
people normally do
i have kind of my own way to do it and
the the dough gets this nice kind of
flaky it's this golden brown flaky
texture
uh the outside is extremely hot if you
bite it you will burn your mouth but the
inside still has just that little bit of
a frozen core because if you've ever
cooked a hot pocket you know that
there's no way to cook it through and
you really shouldn't be cooking it
through in my opinion if you want the
best flavor you want that burning
outside in that frozen core to give you
that contrast yeah i mean good food is
all about contrast you got the the
texture contrast but yeah the
temperature contrast
is really that next level contrast that
that i think hot pockets have really
perfected
i've never had a hot pocket that was
cooked in a way that was both safe and
edible um
anyway uh so yeah that does it for this
episode uh like i said we're gonna do
the uh the great experiment uh trying to
do a live q a september 2nd so hopefully
you'll be able to join us for it we're
going to try to choose a time um you
know we've got a lot of international
listeners across a variety of time zones
so we're going to try to choose a time
zone that that makes sense
and uh we'll do our best with it and we
hope that you will join us
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you